this is nancy pelosi's comments about
the event
she said uh nancy pelosi under fire for
saying george floyd sacrificed himself
for justice that's another newsweek
story
speaker to house nancy pelosi was
criticized on social media tuesday after
she thanked george
for sacrificing his life for justice
pelosi said thank you george floyd
for sacrificing your life for justice
for being there to call out
uh to your mom how heartbreaking was
that call out to your mom i can't
breathe but because of your
because of you and because of thousands
millions of people around the world who
come out of justice
your name will be synonymous with
justice pelosi
was quickly denounced for her remarks
with many users pointing out that floyd
did not voluntarily give up
his life for justice nancy pelosi just
said thank you george floyd for
sacramento
and this is a nutshell is everything
that's wrong with
uh fox woke liberalism conservative talk
liberalism conservative talk shows dan
o'donnell tweeted so
she gives these thoughts right on what
it is was he jesus
well that's kind of what she's uh
unbelievable yeah to make a comment like
that yeah i think that's absurd
okay so that's absurd now that leads to
the event that happened yesterday this
is before before we move on to the next
topic let's get our audience involved
why don't
we do a poll or you know you do the
thumbs up thumbs down ask them what they
think
should he be guilty i mean how do you i
don't know how you want to
pose the question with the thumbs up
thumb down so i'm just asking you to do
it but okay
so did you did you agree
with the verdict of what happened if yes
thumbs up did you not agree with the
verdict of what happened thumbs down and
i'm talking specifically smash the
thumbs up
or the thumbs down right now we're at
452 to 3
is what the ratios are 452 to 3.
yeah i'll see these things myself
because okay so now
452 to 3 it just went up
hold on hold on go ahead go ahead am i
being unreasonable or i'm just stating
the fact that there could be more
evidence to it you're not you're not no
no i'm being honest you're not being
unrealistic i'm playing the other
you actually played both sides on that
no because i i said that i'm divided on
it because if the reality is if there's
evidence
that his net his foot was not on the or
his knee was not on the neck then what
are you gonna do
about that just to your point do you
think his knee on his back
is any better than his neck of course a
hundred times better
if you're on a if you're on the ground
and someone's pushing on your back and
your chest is against the
right the curve on the and you're and
you also can't breathe like the guy
couldn't breathe no no
brother was on his neck that's what it
was on his throat
he couldn't breathe that's where i agree
with you because when he's saying i
can't breathe you gotta really look into
that
yes you already got him surrounded look
it's the same thing that happened with
eric i don't agree with what happened
with the guys
cigarettes that's disgusting yes okay if
you don't mind sam do we have that
do we get that ready uh pat do you mind
if i give uh our friend
uh uh uh before we continue right now
yeah absolutely
i asked him if i could give him a down
payment right on the thousand dollars
that i owe you so i got
three hundred dollars worth of quarterly
is my first down payment to you sir
uh you know and the reason i can't give
you the other 700 right now
is because your president that you voted
for is gonna tax me highly so i have to
tax you as well
so that being said i have three hundred
dollars worth of quarters
i believe in the tax system that we used
to do laundry for life this is
this is 300 worth of quarters i'd like
to say you might count it out and stack
it we will you want to
do that for you am i going to trust i
just want you to go straight to the
casino you can you can uh
you can use it however you like okay
okay and it's uh it's currency
i thought it was going to be pennies
they got its quarters because if it was
pennies you would have been in trouble
right now
so but let me tell you we can you can
take this you can take this down to food
max
they have a coin machine actually we'll
convert this into dollars okay
okay and then and then uh after i do my
taxes we can figure out how i could do
the other 700 for me all right sounds
like a plan so now we're but i gotta
dump
yesterday i asked you bill by the way at
dinner i asked you can i give you a
double favorite did you even come back
bro
to mario and sam for doing unbelievable
but my question to you is
last time i asked you can i give you a
down payment and you said yes
so this is my down payment we're talking
about somebody who makes probably a half
a million dollars a year
if not more he lost a bet legitimately
legitimately lost a bet he's been
ducking me for
for a good four months
pat paid day off i've been like
ricardo quote doesn't have a credit card
it doesn't have to come out hold on hold
on he travels with 200 bucks
basically he makes this much money he
can't give me a thousand brothers listen
to the audience i've paid debt tens of
thousands so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you